voilà alors la semaine dernière on a
fait une nouvelle interview qu'on a
testé sur emmanuelle béart et josiane
balasko une interview impossible ça
s'appelle l'interview et saïda voici
donc l'interview outside à leur tour
jean luc lemoine quels sont les défauts
que doit avoir une femme pour vous
séduire les défauts
beaucoup de mauvais esprit et une
poitrine un peu trop grosse à l'
incident qui vous a fait le plus plaisir
il ya trois jours j'étais en spectacle
et pendant que je jouais il est
quelqu'un qui est dit dans la salle où
il est horrible
il est horrible ça ça me fait plaisir
parce qu'elle a rigolé après la personne
ouais bon si c'était sur mon physique ça
fait la peine mais si c'était pour le
spectacle ça me fait plaisir
le compliment qui vous énerve le plus
c'est quand les gens disent dans la rue
je vous adore franchement je trouve
aussi drôle que gérard muller vous avez
des enfants
non j'en ai pas quand vous en aurez qu
est ce que vous aimeriez qu'il rate le
concours d'entrée à popstars
que leur interdire y est vous que vous
ne vous interdisez pas à vous même du
coucher avec ma femme pour quelles
raisons
seriez vous capable de refuser votre
plus belle histoire d'amour parce que ça
craint je vais quand même pas me marier
avec ma mère un joueur quel est le
talent que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir de
super bien préparé les tripes c'est ça
je m'en fous un petit peu donc non ça ça
m'intéresse pas vraiment quelle est la
blague de votre spectacle qui vous fait
pas rire c'est celle qu'on a vue dans
l'extrait sur les petits enfants qui
préparent enfin les petits asiatiques
qui préparent des magnétoscopes et des
baskets la blague me fait rire mais le
font pas du tout oui par qui
aimeriez-vous être détesté par le mec de
liv tyler
ah ouais j'aurais bien qu'ils me déteste
et qu'il des raisons me détester
quelle phrase ne vous êtes vous jamais
tient aujourd'hui je suis très bien
disque delory
il a les yeux le corps et le propos est
à changer le nom puisqu'elle est là qu
est ce que vous aimeriez qu'on vous
volent à part tennis de sébastien j'ai
un pote sérieusement qui m'a offert un
signe en porcelaine à noël un fort bien
comme le vol avant que jocaste quelques
mimiques marianne drôle george bush
qu'avez-vous fait délibérément à votre
insu ouais alors là j'ai délibérément
pas compris la question là bas si je
crois pas que vous voulez en vibrant
natacha bas tout ce que ma conscience
m'interdirais à et voilà c'est à voir
jean-louis quelle est la meilleure
mauvaises critiques qu'on vous ait fait
à une fois que j'ai un type qui est
sortie du spectacle en plein milieu du
spectacle il a vu mon équipe et leur a
dit c'est honteux autant de cynisme sa
cause de spectacle comme ça qu'il ya la
guerre
j'ai trouvé ça un peu excessive mais sa
jolie peau la dernière question qu'il
faut pas que je me repose et sinon ils
achètent et font reculer
alors